If you have to ask why some animals kill their
young, you’ve never been a parent.
Hello survivors, Julian here for DNews.
Aside from being adorable little bundles of
joy, babies serve an important purpose - They’re
pretty vital to keeping the human race going.
Babies are born, they grow up, they make more
babies.
And yet there are species that intentionally
kill their young and somehow haven’t wiped
themselves off the earth.
Why would they do that?
Ok bear with me here because this is going
to sound paradoxical, but some species kill
and eat their young because it’s good for
the survival of the species.
And there are actually a couple of ways that
could be true.
First off, don’t forget that raising offspring
is expensive, resource-wise.
Baby animals are useless: they can’t find
food on their own, they slow the parents down,
and they’re liable to walk right into the
mouth of a predator because they don’t know
any better.
So if a youngun is born when resources are
already scarce, some mothers may decide it’s
just not worth the effort.
Or, if the little one is sick and the mother
thinks it’s going to die anyway, she may
figure there’s no sense letting a little
snack go to waste.
That appears to be what happened when a sloth
bear in captivity in the Smithsonian’s National
Zoo gave birth to three cubs.
She had raised offspring before so no one
thought there would be an issue.
Then all of a sudden she ate two of them.
Zookeepers intervened to rescue the third
and discovered it was suffering from hypothermia
and an infection, so the hypothesis is the
mother knew they were as good as dead anyway.
Rather than just abandoning them, she ate
them, possibly so the rotting carcass wouldn’t
draw predators back to her den.
Don’t go thinking we’re above all this
either, researchers analyzed cases of human
mothers who killed or abandoned their children
the day they’re born.
The new mothers were typically young, poor,
and without a partner.
In other words, they were short on resources.
And unlike other mothers who kill their children
later, these women had no psychopathology
or suicidal tendencies after they had done
the deed, so the researchers suggested they
killed their offspring because of some instinct
evolved long ago.
If mom doesn’t get you, you’re not necessarily
home free.
When a male lion finally rises to the top
of the hierarchy and can start breeding, they
are known to kill all the cubs in a pride
that aren’t their own.
By doing this, the females become ready to
breed sooner, so he can father cubs with them
and extend his genetic lineage.
That’s right, the females breed with the
guy who killed their baby.
Shakespeare’s got nothing on nature.
Lions aren’t the only ones who do this either;
bottlenose dolphin males will separate calves
they know aren’t their own from their mother
and bash them or launch them into the air.
Male langur monkeys will also kill offspring,
but never their own and never those older
than 6 months.
That lead researchers to conclude it’s not
because they’re indiscriminate monkey murderers;
they’re only killing babies that are still
suckling.
While they’re suckling, their mothers are
producing milk and in these monkeys milk production
inhibits ovulation.
So get the kid out of the picture and the
males have a potential mate sooner.
To counteract this, the females of some species
have developed an ingenious strategy: mate
with everyone.
Bonobo ape females will sleep around so when
a little behbeh is born, nobody knows who
the father is.
Scientists think that’s part of the reason
bonobos are one of the few great apes are
infanticide free.
Pregnant horses will do the same thing.
If a female horse is mated with a male from
outside her herd and then brought back, she
will mate with multiple stallions in her herd
to disguise its paternity.
And if she’s can’t do that, a mare may
actually chemically abort the pregnancy.
This shell game of “who’s your daddy?”
keeps baby bonobos and horses alive.
Just hope they don’t get smart enough to
develop paternity testing.
Animals killing their young because it’s
good for the species sounds like a BS fact
but I swear it’s true.
For more facts that sound made up but aren’t,
check out our friends at Did You Know.
Don’t worry it won’t be as morbid as this
episode.
So some animals kill their own babies, but
which animals don’t care about babies and
just have sex for fun?
We answer that in this video.
Alright it's a wild world out there and there's
a lot of interesting animal stuff to look
into.
If you have any questions, let us know in
the comments, subscribe for more and I'll
see you next time on DNews.